i'm an angel i'm an angel
despite what he may say daniel radcliffe
had his fair share of bloopers filming
the harry potter movies
considering he grew up on the magical
set the boy who lived experienced plenty
of fumbles and poorly timed giggling
fits from fun behind the scenes to
hilarious mistakes on set none of us
quite have any idea what's going on
radcliffe made sure mischief was managed
[Applause]
before he even landed the role of harry
potter daniel radcliffe's adorable
giggle was captured by the crew in his
audition where a prop broke the young
actor's concentration chris clums broke
and make me laugh
it was a pretty great audition since
luckily the actor's personality shone
through and the team knew they'd found
their harry potter
even when he was flubbing up and
laughing radcliffe nailed the essence of
the boy who lived apparently nothing
could shake the young actor while he was
filming the very first harry potter film
while radcliffe may not have been phased
by the world of the film harry potter
did need to be
so sometimes the director would have
actors like warwick davis trying to
surprise the actor so they could really
capture a reaction
make him jump the young actor definitely
wasn't scared in this case he just burst
out laughing
evidently working with child actors can
be tricky daniel radcliffe has had one
very special trick up his sleeve since
the first film that apparently was his
secret to acting
why exactly was he so good at such a
young age a good liar don't admit that
is that why you'll get out there
yes
even when he wasn't performing for the
camera it seems he was entertaining the
crew on set i just couldn't believe my
name was daniel radcliffe and it was on
the credits list
it was amazing it was unbelievable
whether it was another actor or just his
own actions the harry potter actor got
bumped around quite a bit on set for the
second film lucius malfoy actor jason
isaacs got a little too excited with his
walking stick
leaving a young radcliffe totally
vulnerable
as if being knocked over by isaacs
wasn't bad enough radcliffe was the one
who brought on his other onset bump as
he was flailing around when goofing off
between takes
[Music]
with so many young actors on set behind
the scenes was filled with fun and on
occasion some pretty great pranks one of
the absolute best came from the adult
cast members
we enter completely our own world
you know
alan rickman and michael gambin took
advantage of the fact that many of the
young actors were in sleeping bags for a
scene in harry potter and the prisoner
of azkaban they had put
a fart machine
into
my sleeping bag
even though gambin tried to go on with
his lines as usual no one was able to
keep it together on set the dumbledore
actor was pulling double duty since
while he was acting he was also the one
controlling the machine going off
they all may have gone down in their
harnesses in sync but radcliffe had a
bit of a harder time getting back up
evidently it was a struggle for the
actor to figure out exactly how to
maneuver himself as well
it seems pretty in character for the
actor to have this not so suave moment
although considering how much time he
spent in the air on a broomstick playing
quidditch we are a bit surprised that
the simple harness life was a struggle
whoops
radcliffe had his reasons for stepping
on some toes while filming scenes for
the ewo ball the actor didn't get close
to the amount of dance lessons and
rehearsal as his castmates because he
was busy filming all his other
adventurous scenes in the fourth film
this is my big dance day
however according to the actor the skill
level wasn't due to lack of training
instead his missteps were on purpose
because it was a character choice i'm
actually a really fantastic dancer but
because harry's not very good i felt
like a player
while we're not totally convinced
radcliffe absolutely pulled off his
dance moves even if it wasn't the most
impressive dancing
by the time the fourth film came around
daniel radcliffe was showing off his
skills with very impressive stunts
i'm the last of the action heroes
but the actor couldn't always keep it
professional and rock a straight face
while he performed this daring major
stunt flawlessly the illusion was broken
almost immediately after landing when
radcliffe completely corpsed if we were
him we'd probably be crying instead of
laughing after an intense stunt like
that after working together for so many
years rupert grint and daniel radcliffe
were often cracking up when they were
together on set
even in serious scenes grint couldn't
hold it together trying to defend harry
just shot your mouth no one could take
either of them seriously as they burst
into fits of giggles
considering this was the fifth film many
of these actors worked on together it's
no surprise they were like a family on
set
kissing in front of a whole bunch of
cameras and people watching is
intimidating to say the least so it's
not a surprise that radcliffe and katie
leung shared a few laughs while trying
to capture their romantic kiss over and
over and over again at one point it
seemed like everything imaginable was
getting in their way
all that awkward smooching didn't stop
radcliffe from sneaking in an extra kiss
with his co-star though
i'll not kiss you enough today
by the way this was the harry potter
actor's very first on-screen kiss
a person might think it would take a lot
to catch one of the greatest wizards of
all time off guard but apparently if
you're daniel radcliffe all you've gotta
do is step on dumbledore's robes to stop
him moving and the whole scene from
being filmed to be fair the robes do
leave quite the trail
while ron and hermione did their best to
support harry figuratively and literally
it didn't always work out capturing this
scene definitely took a few takes
and probably way more stepping on rupert
grin's head than he would have liked
sometimes the simplest tasks become the
most tricky to film
like just getting up and walking away
considering just how much work radcliffe
did filming the half-blood prince even
doing small bits like this scene in the
dining hall could end up being a
struggle
the walk away never even made the final
cuts so who knows if the actor ever
nailed it at all poor radcliffe wound up
with some pain as a result of acting
opposite emma watson the actress got a
bit too into character and the harry
potter actor wasn't able to ignore the
very very real pain he was feeling
you're laughing because he hit me so
hard
this flub meant the take couldn't be
used so they were forced to continue
rolling until they nailed the shot
preferably in a way that didn't further
injure radcliffe while fleur de la cour
actress clemons poisie might have been
knowledgeable about how to remove a bra
daniel radcliffe was in need of some
pointers when he played fleur disguised
as himself
while he may not have been able to take
the clothing on and off simply he did
love getting to dress in it
fantastic in women's clothing we just
love seeing how fun all those years on
set were for the harry potter actor the
cast and crew had become like family
which was a major contributor to how
great a time everyone had behind the
scenes
which blooper is your favorite